ja vielen Dank wir reden natürlich heute
morgen um die Tatsache dass wir einen
neuen Schirm gebaut gekriegt haben von
der Bundesregierung der Abwehr schon mit
200 Milliarden Euro die gasumlage sollte
ja morgen greifen ist jetzt abgesetzt
per Verordnung sie wird nicht greifen es
wird also eine Entlastung für die Bürger
geben und keine Belastung die
Zielrichtung das Sagen unisono fast alle
ist richtig aber warum so spät und was
heißt das jetzt eigentlich für die
Bürger das will ich besprechen mit
meinen beiden Gesprächspartnern heute
ich begrüße ganz herzlich Lukas Köhler
von der FDP der stellvertretender
Fraktionsvorsitzende und in der gleichen
Funktion für die cdu/csu Matthias
Mittelberg Herr Köhler gab es gerade
gesagt was bedeutet das jetzt für mich
als Gaskunden viele haben von ihren
Stadtwerken schon neue Rechnungen
gekriegt es gibt bei anderen Personen
Abschlagszahlungen was müssen die jetzt
machen
noch gar nichts das ganze kommt ja über
die Stadtwerke und deswegen ist das
einzige und das ist die gute Nachricht
die Belastung wird nicht kommen
jedenfalls nicht die Belastung über die
gasumlage die Preise sind ja leider
trotzdem noch hoch genug da tut aber
auch der Abwehr schön etwas gegenüber
den gaspreisdeckel muss der Bürger denn
Einspruch einlegen wenn jetzt eine neue
Rechnung ins Haus kommt oder
ignorierte sie einfach wie wie ist das
Verfahren also es wird sicherlich sehr
zeitnah auch von den Gasversorgern von
den Betreibern von denen die in die
Rechnung schicken noch mal eine neue
Information dazu kommen wieder mit jetzt
umgegangen wird das Gute ist die
gasumlage fällt so nicht an Himmelberg
die Union hat das ja immer gefordert die
gasumlage muss weg wurde hier beschimpft
von Robert Habeck der vielleicht der
letzte war der in dieser gasumlage
festhalten wollte am Schluss auch nicht
mehr einen Tag vor Toresschluss das Ding
jetzt zu kippen ist immerhin die
politische Richtung richtig oder
ja die Erkenntnis kommt spät aber sie
ist dann doch gekommen die gasumlage war
wirklich Mist von Anfang an wir müssen
natürlich jetzt in dieser schwierigen
Phase die Gasverbraucher entlasten und
nicht belasten das hat die Regierung
jetzt auf den letzten Metern erkannt die
ganze Umlage war auch eine
Fehlkonstruktion jetzt hat man sich
durchgerungen zu dem was sinnvoll ist
nämlich zu einer Gaspreis Bremse und das
halten wir jedenfalls für diskutabel wie
das ausgestaltet wird wissen wir noch
nicht da sind wir mal sehr gespannt was
die Regierung uns da auf den Tisch legt
jetzt ein bisschen ungewöhnlich 200
Milliarden werden vorgegeben und wie das
ausgestaltet werden soll soll jetzt eine
Expertenkommission bis Mitte des Monats
erarbeiten da hat nicht nur Friedrich
Merz gestern gesagt eigentlich müsste es
ja andersrum sein warum ist das in der
falschen Reihenfolge ich glaube die
Reihenfolge ist genau richtig die
Expertenkommission muss ja wissen
welchen Spielraum sie hat wie sie
arbeiten kann welche Rahmenbedingungen
gelten aber eine ein gaspreisdeckel also
ein Eingreifen in einen Markt der jetzt
schon super volatil ist der geht hoch
und runter niemand weiß ganz genau in
welche Richtung er sich bewegen wird wir
haben jetzt die Pipelines gesehen wir
haben den Druck der den die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger haben den sehen und spüren
wir alle deswegen ist es richtig dass
jetzt Expertinnen und Experten sich
überlegen wie können wir die
unterschiedlichen Bedingungen die
notwendig sind um den Gaspreis
runterzubekommen aber trotzdem dafür zu
sorgen dass genug eingespart wird wie
können wir das umsetzen wegen der
Schritt ist völlig richtig also Schritt
ist richtig die Expertenkommission
entscheidet Mitte Oktober bis dahin
fallen die Rechnung an bis dahin wollen
die Gasversorger auch gerettet werden
uniper hat jeden Monat 100 Millionen
Verlust wie wird das gestaltet haben sie
es verstanden Herr Mittelberg nein das
habe ich noch nicht verstanden weil dazu
eben konkretes noch nicht auf dem Tisch
liegt das einzige was wir jetzt gesehen
haben ist dieses Preisschild von 200
Milliarden es sollen jetzt 200
Milliarden Schulden in einem Sondertopf
angesammelt werden und daraus will man
dann verschiedene Maßnahmen finanzieren
etwa die gaspreisbremse oder auch die
Stützung der Unternehmen und auch die
Stützung der Unternehmen die Gas
ankaufen und anderes mehr wie das
konkret verstehen soll wissen wir nicht
und die Reihenfolge wie jetzt
vorgegangen wird ist natürlich
tatsächlich genau falsch man hätte es
genau andersrum machen müssen man muss
erst identifizieren welche Maßnahmen man
macht und dann kann man sagen wie viel
Geld man dafür braucht den ganzen Sommer
über hat ihre Koalition wirklich mit
internen Streitereien verdaddelt anders
kann man das nicht sagen diese
Expertenkommission hätten ja schon seit
zwei Monaten eingesetzt sein können
hätten ihre Ergebnisse längst vorgelegt
haben können dann wüssten wir wie jetzt
eine Strom- oder gaspreisbremse aussehen
könnte natürlich will auch noch einen
Punkt dazu 200 Milliarden sagen sie da
weiß die Expertenkommission womit sie
handhaben kann 34 Milliarden sind per se
schon mal weg weil das sagen die
energiebetreiber brauchen wir als
Stützung bis Dezember also da kommt eine
Menge zusammen schon mal an posten und
ich wage mal die These dass es hinterher
gar nicht 200 Milliarden sind sondern es
muss da noch was drauf kommen schätze
ich mal
den genauen Bedarf sehen wir ja erst in
der Zukunft wir wissen ja nicht und wir
wussten bis Anfang der Woche auch nicht
ob nicht doch noch Gas zum Beispiel über
Nord Stream 1 kommen würde deswegen bin
ich auch ein bisschen überrascht über
die Aussagen der Union die habe bisher
noch gar keinen Vorschlag vorgelegt hat
sondern bisher gefordert hat
was sie will aber wie es konkret
aussehen wollen nicht doch Umlage
abgeschafft werden soll wussten wir
bisher auch nicht und ich glaube die
aktuelle Geschwindigkeit zeigt dass
jetzt Anschläge auf einem Pipeline
verübt werden dass wir den Krieg in der
Ukraine so weiterlaufen sehen wie er
bisher läuft zeigt ja dass wir schnell
und kurzfristig und gezielt reagieren
müssen und dafür braucht es auch eine
Kommission und ich glaube dafür braucht
es Expertinnen und Experten die dann ein
gutes ein funktionierendes Instrument
organisieren und das tun wir jetzt eine
Regierung die soweit geht und sagt die
Gaspreise steigen an und wir legen dann
noch mal 2,4 Cent drauf hat hier gerade
noch mal die Kurve gekriegt aber die
Opposition wie gesagt hat sie immer
einfach kann kritisieren hatten Sie denn
Gegenvorschläge die sich schon erläutert
haben sehr konkreten Gegenvorschläge da
müssen sie aufmerksamer die Zeitung
lesen wir haben Ende August eine
Klausurtagung gemacht in Bayern und
haben auf der Klausurtagung sehr konkret
einen Vorschlag gemacht nämlich eine
gaspreisbremse die haben wir auch auf
unserem Bundesparteitag beschlossen
nämlich 65 75 Prozent des
vorjahresverbrauchs zu einem
garantierten Preis zur Verfügung zu
stellen das ist wahrscheinlich etwa das
was sie jetzt machen wollen und den
übrigen Teil nämlich fünf Optionen
dann können Sie gerne was dazu sagen
ich stelle jetzt erstmal das Modell da
und die Finanzierung kommt dann
hinterher das Modell was wir
vorgeschlagen haben ist sehr konkret und
wahrscheinlich werden sie ziemlich genau
das umsetzen was wir schon seit einem
Monat vorschlagen und ich sage es noch
mal ihre Expertenkommission hätte schon
längst arbeiten können die haben sie
mühselig von paar Tagen jetzt ins Werk
gesetzt die gasumlage hätten sie schon
vor über einem Monat hier wegräumen
können wir haben sie zweimal im Bunde
hier zur Abstimmung gestellt haben
beantragt dass sie die gasumlage
weghauen das haben sie nicht getan
sondern haben zweimal für ihre gasumlage
gestimmt Herr Harbeck hat uns in der
letzten Woche noch beschimpft weil wir
die Abschaffung der gasumlage gefordert
also ich sag's jetzt mal ganz ehrlich
man kann sie jetzt dazu beglückwünschen
dass sie endlich auf den richtigen Fahrt
kommen aber mehr auch wirklich nicht tut
mir leid sie haben die in der letzten
Woche war auf einem wunderbare Debatte
sie haben gesagt die Gasanlage muss weg
aber sie haben nicht einmal nicht einer
ihrer Redner in der Debatte und ich war
ja auch mit dabei hat einmal gesagt naja
dafür müssen wir eben dann Geld
aufnehmen oder hat gesagt dieses
funktionieren soll ich glaube es ist
richtig zu kritisieren das Aufgabe der
Opposition das finde ich absolut richtig
aber Sie müssen natürlich dann die ganze
Geschichte
einen anderen Aspekt einführen neben dem
Geld fällt ja auf dass gerade
bei auf der Seite wo das Problem
eigentlich herrscht nämlich auf der
Angebotsseite woher kriegen wir die
Energie da passiert reichlich wenig wenn
ich gestern den Bundesfinanzminister und
FDP-Vorsitzende in einer Fernsehsendung
reden höher der wir brauchen demnächst
die fünf Atomkraftwerke am Netz dann
können viele sagen jawohl der Mann hat
natürlich recht aber er setzt sich ja
nicht durch in dieser Ampel wenn ich
sehe dass heute ein Anteil in dem
Deutschen Bundestag der von der Union
schon mehrfach gestellt auch von der
Ampel durchgewinkt wird nämlich das
Biomasse endlich nicht mehr gedeckelt
wird da muss man doch sagen hat diese
Ampel aus welchen Gründen auch immer an
der energieangebotsseite bisher völlig
versagt das kann ich auf in keiner
Hinsicht so unterschreiben wir haben es
geschafft dass wir auf gas-seite 91% der
Speicher den höchsten Füllstand zu
diesem Zeitpunkt im Jahr bisher
hinbekommen haben das haben wir über
klare Regulierungen geschafft wir haben
es geschafft FSK News in einer
Geschwindigkeit zu an also schwimmende
lng-schiffe in einer Geschwindigkeit ans
Netz anzuschließen dass die wir noch
nicht gesehen haben und wir haben jetzt
diese Woche dafür gesorgt dass immer
mehr kohlekapazitäten und das ist viel
mehr als die Atomenergie mit ans Netz
gehen wir haben diese Woche gesehen dass
der Wirtschaftsminister zwei weitere
Atomkraftwerke schon mal auf jeden Fall
verlängert und über die weiter sprechen
wir jetzt wir sind handlungsfähig und
wir haben den ganzen Sommer den das
ganze Jahr über bewiesen wie schnell wie
viele Gesetze wie viele Dinge wir tun
können damit dieses Land Kapazitäten hat
wir müssen aber natürlich diese Watte
weiterführen muss ich doch noch mal
einen Haken gerade was die gefüllten
Gasspeicher angehen ganz prima
Geschichte die reichen für zweieinhalb
drei Monate da muss noch irgendwo
Energie herkommen aber das Gas kam vor
allen Dingen aus Russland das wird im
nächsten Winter dann nicht mehr der Fall
sein und die FDP guckt zu wie eben die
Atomkraftwerke eigentlich nicht
angeschlossen werden weiterlaufen und
jetzt werden sie im April nächsten
Jahres abgestellt das wird keine Lösung
sein für das kommende Jahr also bisher
gibt es nur den Vorschlag des
Wirtschaftsministers noch kein Gesetz
und ich habe bisher noch nicht gesehen
dass die Bundesregierung beschlossen hat
dass nur zwei der Kraftwerke
weiterlaufen wir setzen uns ganz klar
dafür ein dass die weiteren
Kernkraftwerke die wir haben die drei
bestehenden auf jeden Fall weiterlaufen
bis 2024 wenn nötig müssen wir auch
weitere Brennstäbe bestellen weil jetzt
brauchen wir jede Kapazität aber die
Aussage dass wir nichts gemacht haben
ist im Gegenteil genau falsch wir haben
jetzt eine Menge dazu angeschlossen eine
Menge dazu angere alles weitere
Kapazitäten des Netz kommt die Union war
massiv daran beteiligt die Atomkraft in
Deutschland zurückzufahren unter anderem
ist die Union auch daran beteiligt
gewesen neben der SPD natürlich dass wir
völlig einseitig abhängig geworden sind
von den Russen und vom russischen Gas da
wäre natürlich eine Entschuldigung mal
angesagt dennoch das macht es ja nicht
besser die Frage wie die Ampel sich
jetzt verhält auf der Angebotsseite die
ist sicherlich diskutabel also man hätte
die Kohlekraftwerke viel früher
hochfahren müssen Herr Habeck hat
monatelang gezögert dann hat er
schließlich getan mittlerweile sind zwei
zwei Kohlekraftwerke in Niedersachsen am
Netz im Übrigen noch kein einziges in
Deutschland das ist schon ein Problem
die Kernkraftwerke darüber diskutieren
sie und streiten sie in dieser Ampel
jetzt ich weiß nicht ein halbes Jahr
oder noch länger jedenfalls seit
Ausbruch des Krieges man fragt sich auch
das hätte längst entschieden werden
können die Brennstäbe hätten längst
bestellt sein können und dann wäre klar
dass mindestens in diesem und im
nächsten Winter wir die drei Kraftwerke
die jetzt im Netz sind weiter zur
Verfügung haben ich wünsche Ihnen bei
den internen streiten dass sie sich da
durchsetzen Herr Köhler drücke ich Ihnen
wirklich die Daumen aber das jetzt hier
schön zu reden diesen internen zwang das
finde ich ehrlich gesagt nicht in
Ordnung dass sie sagen es sind jetzt
erst seit sechs Monaten sind wir in der
Debatte darüber wie wir die Kohlekraft
Verlängern der 24 September ist nicht so
viel länger her sie sagen also genau das
richtige wir haben es geschafft jetzt
schon eine Menge dafür zu tun aus der
Kohle Reserve übrigens im Gesetz das ja
von ihrer Regierung mitgetragen wurde
und mitkam die Kohle aus der Reserve
rauszuziehen Niedersachsen liegt ja auch
in Deutschland deswegen gibt es auch in
Deutschland jetzt schon Kohlekraftwerke
die am Netz sind und weitere sind gerade
RWE ja gerade angekündigt werden jetzt
an als Kapazitäten ans Netz gehen dass
Energie dass ersatzkraftwerke
bereitstellungsgesetz dass er genau
diese coole regelt ist vor der
Sommerpause durch den Bundestag gegangen
also wenige Monate nach Beginn des
Krieges wir bauen lng-terminals und
Infrastruktur im halben Jahr und das ist
auch die Antwort auf die gasfrage weil
im kommenden Jahr wird kein russisches
Gas mehr fließen aber natürlich werden
wir dann die LNG Termin haben in großer
Zahl wir werden die Infrastruktur dafür
haben deswegen mache ich mir auch da
keine Sorgen dass wir es hinbekommen im
nächsten Jahr weiter Gas einzuspeichern
der Bürger jedenfalls versteht nicht
mehr was im Einzelnen läuft und an was
ist auch immer liegen mag aber gestern
kam die erschreckende Zahl das 14
Prozent mehr gasverbraucht wurde als im
vergangenen September das sind natürlich
Zustände es kann so nicht weitergehen
deswegen das zeigt ja auch dass gerade
bei der Angebotsseite viel viel mehr
passieren muss auf der gasangebotsseite
haben sie natürlich eine riesige
Herausforderung weil es gibt einen
Weltmarkt und der hat halt nur leider
eine limitierte Anzahl von Gasmolekülen
zur Verfügung beim Strom ist das anders
beim Strom schaffen über die Biomasse
über die erneuerbaren Energien über
jetzt auch dann die Kernkraftwerke und
vor allen Dingen über die Kohlekraft das
was wir brauchen über den Winter aber
Gas ist physisch knapp deswegen ist es
notwendig dass die Industrie die hat
schon viel gespart und die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger sparen wenn sie den September
vergleichen haben sie recht es ist mehr
vergasverbraucht worden aber es war auch
ein drastisch kälterer September als die
anderen Winter das heißt auch die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger haben glaube ich
verstanden dass das Gas einsparen müssen
aber wenn es sehr sehr kalt über den
Winter wird dann wird es natürlich dazu
führen dass wir mehr Gas verbrauchen und
ich glaube auch diesen Appell kann man
an jeden und jede Bürgerin rechten
Momenten müssen wir alle was dafür tun
dass wir kein keine gasmangelage
bekommen zehn Prozent Inflation wurde
gestern gemeldet und nächstes Jahr
könnte es noch viel schlimmer aussehen
ist es da eigentlich richtig so viel
Geld aufzunehmen von Seiten des Staates
das ist ja jetzt über den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds ein
Trick des Finanzministers er belebt ihn
wiederholt Kredite darüber sind die
eigentlich dann Teil des
Bundeshaushaltes fürs nächste Jahr nein
so wie es geplant ist sind diese Kredite
nicht Teil des Bundeshaushalts nicht für
dieses Jahr nicht für nächstes Jahr
sondern es ist tatsächlich eine
Schattenhaushalt der neben dem
Bundeshaushalt eingerichtet wird und in
dem dann diese bis zu 200 Milliarden
geparkt werden sollen die man dann nach
und nach über drei Jahre abschließen
lassen will das ist die Technik das
macht die ganze Sache natürlich sehr
sehr Intransparenz das muss man sagen
aber im Kern
will ich auch durchaus zugestehen wir
müssen natürlich was machen um den
Verbrauchern zu helfen aber auch um
unseren Betrieben und Unternehmen zu
helfen also wir müssen jetzt am Ende den
Gaspreis ich sage das mal runter
subventionieren weil die Leute natürlich
nicht in vier fünf sechsfachen Gaspreis
zahlen können das ist nicht zumutbar
also muss was passieren was ich bei
dieser Regierung sehr vermisse ist dass
man mal irgendwie in die Aufgabenkritik
guckt und mal sagt gibt es nicht
irgendeine Stelle an der wir auch was
einsparen können können wir nicht auch
Mittel einsetzen die wir jetzt zu
zusätzlich zur Verfügung haben diese
Regierung macht im Moment ums klar zu
sagen ein Riesengeschäft mit dieser
großen Inflation weil ja die Preise so
exorbitant gestiegen sind verdienen sie
deutlich mehr über die Umsatzsteuer das
sind pro inflationspunkt etwa 10
Milliarden davon die werden quasi
einfach so rausgeballert mit ihren
entlastungspaketen per Gießkanne statt
diese Mittel zielgerichtet schon in
diesem Fond geparkt zu haben
ermittelberger sie können nicht mehr
antworten drin geht's nicht los vielen
Dank dass sie da waren